was geht hier soll max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video wir
spielen heute minecraft 1.9 survival
games ich bin sehr gespannt wie das
ganze wird ich habe ja bisher nur so ein
kleines 1.9 pvp duell gehabt mit - tut
falls jetzt noch nicht gesehen haben
erst einmal anschauen aber ich bin
einfach echt gespannt so wie sich das
verhält wie ich mich schlage ich habe
den server auf dem man das zocken kann
in einem video von dehner gesehen und da
hat er das auch gemacht ich darf mir
direkt kommt dass probierst du auch mal
aus ich habe richtig viel entscheidung
bald gras schon mal auf dem server noch
nie gezockt aber anscheinend scheinen
die an enchantment bartels nicht zu
sparen so der hat seine angeblich doch
so krasse holz axt
aber ich hab mal herausgefunden also ich
habe ein bisschen gelesen dazu und die
holz macht anscheinend zwar tatsächlich
mehr schaden als ein schwert aber
doppelt so großen cool da und wenn man
also jetzt ein stein schwert ohne stein
axt hat dann hat das stein schwert fünf
angriffe an genau und die steinachs
vermute ich jetzt einfach mal acht
angriff schaden
der unterschied ist aber dass man mit
dem schwert doppelt so schnell schlagen
kann wenn man also gut hits landet dann
macht man mit einem stein schwert in 12
sekunden 10 angriff schaden und in 10 2
sekunden macht man allerdings dafür mit
einem in der stein achsen macht man
allerdings sind wir gleich acht angriff
schaden das heißt es wird sehr sehr
krass das wird sehr sehr extrem auf
ammann kommen ich weiß gar nicht wo ok
presse der duh steht einfach direkt vor
meinem gesicht wartet erstmal ganz
entspannt bis er mich angreift der hat
es zum beispiel eine holz achse aber ich
glaube nicht dass er uns damit
gefährlich werden kann aber ich fand es
auf jeden fall cool zu sehen dass das
thema sich da relativ gut geschlagen hat
damit klar voraus kann einfach annehmen
dass byebye war oder so jetzt die karten
relativ neu gemischt werden sage ich mal
aber ich finde es generell sehr
interessant dass diese möglichkeit
geschaffen wird dadurch mehr oder
weniger so der kämpft er einfach nach
normalem ppp ich dachte eigentlich
relativ gutes equipment scheint nicht
wirklich der fall zu sein
ich probier aber noch mein bestes
weiterhin und das ist wirklich seit
einer gefühlten team sind oder nicht das
seit einer gefühlten ewigkeit
die erste pvp ist weil games runde die
ich wieder spiele
zu den typen habe ich mir schon mal
geholt so ich weiß gar nicht ob man hier
schilder haben kann falls ja muss man
sich wahrscheinlich kräften und ich weiß
aber noch ganzes trafen rezept falls ihr
denn überhaupt kraft bar sind den
kriegste kran ig kikra deloitte deloitte
im chat sei es aber okay den typen
schnappen uns jetzt erstmal sofern er
nicht weggeschnappt wird von den
freundlichen kollegen
zack zack zack ich glaube das ist gerade
echt ok meinem einer hitserie wurde
beendet und ein hätten das werkseitig
das werkseitig dass das ding so der typ
hat auch mit seiner holz mit seiner
steinachs müsste er jetzt selbst wenn er
wenn er häufiger trifft sich dann wer
mich besiegen aber ihr seht leute ist
meine erste runde die ich spiele mein
kommentieren ist zwar gerade etwas nicht
on point
aber dafür haben wir schon den ein oder
anderen kiel gemacht equipment mäßig
sieht gut aus
auch an einsteiger wie am start
ich weiß gar nicht wo man entscheiden
kanada ungarn entstanden das ganze
natürlich auch ohne optimalen da ist er
noch wenn hier aus ist für die 1.9 aber
halb so wild
es läuft ja relativ gut nach missouri
verbrennung born eis haben wir auf jeden
fall was ordentliches am start
so gibt es ein kompass gibt es leider
nicht wie gesagt schaut sehr gut aus bis
er die runde kann man lassen
so kommt dran leute ein bisschen crêpes
abladen ich denke mal dass er mit dem
feuer entscheiden und echt glück gehabt
haben die nehme ich mir vielleicht auch
dazu ich habe schon ausprobiert gab es
wahrscheinlich so ziemlich jeder
ausprobiert ob man so wenn man mit einer
axt schlägt zack direkt rüber wechseln
kann
aber da haben auch die verzögerung die
man sowieso hätte gehen da vorne ist
auch schon der nächste name wenn ich hab
ich da gerade jemanden gesehen meine ich
allerdings ist der kollege und ich würde
sagen den schnappen wir uns doch direkt
als nächstes der hat jetzt echt kein
allzu gutes equipment mit rennen bis
jetzt nichts mehr
aber der bogen mit vielen anscheinend
die nehmen wir doch gerne ab und zack
zack
ok ich regeneriere nicht das war
bisschen unvorsichtig von mir habe ich
gerade nicht darauf geschaut auf meinen
hunger balken die sind auf jeden fall
deutlich wichtiger geworden kann man
sagen was man will habe es aber nicht
mein normales fadenkreuz weil ich noch
mit dem normalen sex spiele und selbst
noch nichts gemacht habe ich weiß auch
gar nicht ob ich nochmal mein kranarm
ipek updaten soll oder ob es gar
komplett lasse
der typ hat auf jeden fall fehler am
start man kann sagen was mir war okay
jetzt hat uns gerade in einer relativ
guten serie gehabt
ich weiß gar nicht warum hat mir so
unendlich viele pfeile
wir passen einfach schön auf und
regeneriert hier echt unglaublich
schnell und warten darauf dass der gute
mann uns besuchen kommt zitterpartie
schreibt da ist er gast der da vorne
kann das geld gar nicht zoomen auf jeden
fall scheint ein deutscher zu sein war
okay also ich mein name ist echt
schlecht ich hätte nicht gedacht dass
das der zu so einem großen teil sage ich
mal von meinem ressort spec abhängig ist
wenn ich mein eigenes orsbeck oder ob
die feinde hat kann ich ja so viel
besser essen habe ich auf jeden fall
größer denn der kollege
handelskammern ok anscheinend ist gerade
jemand gestorben
nicht mehr nicht mal ein gegner der
schießt hier noch aus dem hinterhalt
aber ich kann das einfach nur ich kann
einfach nicht sehen ich werde glaube ich
mich erstmal auf den weg machen wobei
vielleicht den den gegner kann ich mir
vielleicht noch schmecken so mit
verbrennungen kann man auch mal ein
bisschen die cool down phase sage ich
mal von den schwertern kelek das tut mir
leid aber ich will die ohne gewinnen
kann man die cool down phase von seinem
schwert ein bisschen umgehen sagt alles
klar schön voll essen weil es hilft die
andere wenn sie im pfalz sind nicht
können kann man sind die gerade am team
ich hoffe doch sehr dass sie es nicht
sind aber es scheint mir fast so ich
weiß gar nicht ob man das darf hier in
auf dem server beziehungsweise in den
runden davor aber ich kann echt nicht
ziel mit dem ding absolut gar nicht das
dauert irgendwie länger bis man sein
zeug gegessen hat er bis gefühl
leute wir müssen mein aim entschuldigen
den ich hier mit dem mit dem resource
per kabel er anscheinend noch einer
gestorben
ich weiß nicht ob er dafür irgendwie
nimmt den erstmal kollege und dann noch
ein hit reingedrückt
anscheinend kann er mit seinen ändert
wie auch immer bekommen hat gerade nicht
allzu viel anfangen
sehr schön leute je zwei player
ich freue mich hier grad schon schreiben
doch alle die die anscheinend fehlt auch
eine junior first game auf sowie games
erscheinen habe ich das ich gewonnen es
steht hier zwar noch zwei players aber
leute das war meine erste runde gehen
und ich hab sie gewann ein guter start
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
7 k s ein wohin ich würde sagen leute
die axt ist zwar ganz cool
aber wenn man einigermaßen genau ist
dann ist es glaube ich immer noch nach
wie vor besser mit schwertern zu kämpfen
ich habe das video hat euch gefallen das
war meine allererste runde minecraft
sowie games in der version 1.9 und ja
auch dann bis zum nächsten mal macht's
gut
und bis dahin tschüss